[Music]
i am jess holtz and i normally make
artwork with the scanning electron
microscope
to create these sort of alien landscapes
this time i actually imaged the moon and
the sun my dad's telescope
i was just sort of struck by how
peering down the eyepiece
of a telescope feels a lot like peering
down the eyepiece of the microscope just
the way you have to sort of hold your
head and eyes at a certain angle
and the way the image sort of evades you
i also looked at the sun
so um this is just through my cell phone
through a filter
this is through the telescope now um
kind of like in the palm of your hand
and then the next slide
here is the final image and you can see
a little dark speck a sunspot
on it and i was sort of amazed
at the fact that the sunspot could be
possibly the size of the earth
now in microscopy you see a lot of junk
um like maybe little
dark specks or
a lot of debris but usually these things
are like 100 nanometers and you know
very inconsequential
but um on the sun this thing is like the
size of the earth that just kind of blew
my mind
[Music]